[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the second to last bonus show
of the year programming announcement we
will be off on friday new year's eve
december 31st there will be no new show
it is not a cancellation of the show
there just won't be a new show on that
day and then we will be back on uh on
monday
let's get right into it sort of a
surprisingly big news week this week
which often you would say well things
just happen it's not like anyone's
controlling that in the last week of the
year there isn't a lot of news but
there's less of a certain type of news
typically legislative news there's less
and that type of thing but a lot of
different things happening and one of
those things is that harry reid the
longtime us senator from nevada
democratic leader for a period of time
has passed away at the age of 82
and
three decades in congress
he um
has a number of different important
legislative battles and accomplishments
in his uh career and so many different
democrats including chuck schumer
um barack obama and many others putting
out statements and saying that you know
he he was not flashy pat in the sense
that many
celebrity politicians are
but he was a guy with a very interesting
background truly modest beginnings from
an interesting state of nevada which is
it's just an interesting state
culturally for a lot of different
reasons his father was an actual minor
um and a guy that really is a
significant player i mean when you think
about
significant players in the senate
for getting things done in the last 30
years you have to think about harry reid
yeah it was interesting learning about
his life like harry reid was actually a
boxer in his youth yes which i found to
be very surprising and then also before
he worked in congress he was actually a
u.s capitol police officer also
interesting as well and uh yeah i mean
definitely a lot of significance some
people blame him for some of the
increased political polarization that
we've seen over the past 10 20 years or
so because like in the 2012 race exam
for example when it was obama versus
romney
reid alleged that romney didn't pay his
taxes which you know wasn't entirely
true we can say uh but when asked about
it later on
reid sort of doubled down and said well
romney didn't win did he uh and then
also there were things like he said let
republicans cry about it when the
affordable care act got passed he
obviously got rid of the filibuster rule
when it came to
executive appointments and for judges
not supreme court justices mcconnell did
that but just for regular
run-of-the-mill judges so he definitely
did have a big impact obviously he was
instrumental in passing obama obama's
stimulus package and the affordable care
act so definitely a lot of achievements
under his belt
but yeah certainly not a household name
we can say he's not one of these
celebrity politicians no he's more the
type of person that if you follow
politics you know about him but he has
not entered the political milieu like
aoc has uh and to achieve that sort of
recognition
in a way
he sort of played the hardball that in
the
last few years we've said we would like
democrats to play more often and sort of
give republicans a taste of their own
medicine with obstructing when when
politically advantageous and he did some
of the tactical things that we don't
often see democrats do as much more
recently
right and yeah i mean sometimes he'll
get the blame for sort of beginning that
era of politics if you will but if that
serves to be effective then i suppose
that it's good that he did that and i
wonder how he'll compare to chuck
schumer and some of these future senate
majority leaders as this is sort of the
way to do things now uh ultimately you
know the future will tell us what
transpires there but certainly he had a
big impact he served for a long long
time
and also he retired relatively early
compared to some other
uh us senators and these politicians who
like to stay in office until they're 95
years old but i suppose maybe being
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer a few
years ago had something to play with
that decision a really interesting harry
reid story is that
he at one point was the
chair of the nevada gaming commission
and of course
gambling in nevada and vegas is very mob
connected and he wrote in his memoir
that after leaving the post
his wife found a bomb in the family car
which is which is just a crazy story
yeah definitely a target of the mob we
have to imagine he also served in u.s
congress before becoming a senator he
was also the youngest lieutenant
governor in nevada's history so that's
quite the track record he also went to
georgetown university after having to
hitchhike to high school every day when
he was back home growing up in nevada so
you know sort of a rags to riches type
of story and that can always be
commendable uh no matter who it is so 82
years old the passing of harry reid and
we will i we might have a little more
coverage of that on tomorrow's show
potentially um but a guy that i mean
when i started following politics and
covering politics a really a major
player i mean it was probably once a
week harry reid would be mentioned in
the the early iterations of the david
pakman show
in oklahoma the oklahoma state
legislature
continues to really not deal with policy
there's a new bill that's been proposed
which would limit how slavery is taught
in schools and it would ban teaching
that one race is the unique oppressor or
victim in slavery's history now
there's there's two sides to this story
and there's not to let me let me be
clear there's two sides to the story of
this bill
one side of it
is that
these are not good faith
legislative proposals these are
proposals that are looking to build on
the momentum of right-wing focus on
so-called critical race theory etc and
they are continuing to fight what is
essentially a culture war of sorts and
it is completely in bad faith
that being said
i actually think it's fine when slavery
is taught
see here's the thing
there's so many how do i even unpack the
layers in the united states
the
99 or 100 percent of slavery related
curriculum is about the enslaving of
black people by white people in the
united states
and so
in that context
it's logical that people would get the
impression
that slavery in the u.s has been
essentially exclusively the enslavement
of black people by white people
globally there are exceptions to that
and i have no problem with teaching that
it is not
unique
to white people to be the enslavers and
it is not unique to black people to be
the enslaved but it is number one a
requirement to teach more world history
which is often not really done in the
united states public schools or not done
enough so first you've got to expand the
curriculum if you want to introduce that
you've got to expand the curriculum and
number two it's still accurate to say
that historically it's been mostly white
people enslaving non-white people you
know so so if we really want to take
this seriously like if these people were
acting in good faith pat there's a
really good academic conversation to
have about this issue of how slavery
should be taught
they're not actually acting in good
faith
yeah i mean if you actually want to give
a comprehensive education as to the
history of slavery in the world
obviously you would mention that
specific fact that it's not exclusively
a racial thing it just has been in the
united states but that's the thing if
you're teaching american history
specifically you can't divorce those two
things because the entirety of slavery
in the u.s has been a racial thing has
been white people uh putting black
people into slavery and you can't just
sort of avoid that or try to get rid of
the culpability because that has been
the experience here and it seems that
that's what the bill is trying to do
it's trying to make it seem as though
america doesn't have any more
culpability than other nations for the
institution of slavery which you can't
really argue when plenty of other
countries like britain and france and
denmark and mexico
outlawed slavery before the united
states did
and also it it just has all these
stipulations which try to argue that
america was no worse off than any of
these other countries and i think it's
obvious what this legislator is trying
to do here
trying to wash our hands free of this
horrible institution that yes did take
place in the u.s for a lot longer it did
require a war for us to finally get rid
of and you know we obviously have some
guilt over it collectively and that has
to be taught in schools because
otherwise you're just trying to
whitewash our history and obviously
that's why you know so many republicans
especially are trying to push this
because they don't want to have america
perceived to have any faults in its
history at all uh which you can't get
away with saying right and if we were if
these people were functioning in good
faith and and they they've said let's
rebuild the curriculum on slavery from
the ground up i would say great
let's expand how much world history we
teach in public schools
let's include that there were white
europeans enslaved in ancient rome
in the ottoman empire you've got the
history of slavic slaves
uh in crimea there's a history of
slavery
um you can look at barbary the barbary
coast of north africa and slavery there
the thing is
none of the history of those areas is
even being taught for the most part so
when you want to only include the fact
that there were also
slaves that were white there and
otherwise not teach anything else about
it with the goal of diminishing the the
scope of american enslavement of black
people that's when it's clearly in bad
faith and out of context yeah it's
obvious what they're trying to do here
they're clearly giving the game away but
what's also interesting is how like this
bill seems to be a way for the right to
push back against so-called critical
race theory in the 1619 project but it's
interesting how they're not just saying
things like okay well this bill will
make it so that curricula cannot teach
that black people can't be racist or
some of these so-called woke things that
they allege is going on in schools right
it doesn't just cut it there it goes
further and makes all of these claims
about how you can't just argue that
america alone uh has this racist history
or had this racial dynamic when it came
to slavery right and you can't argue
that america had slavery for
longer as an institution than some of
these other countries did like they're
really trying to push the boundaries
here and i think that's what is really
revealing about these people and how
they think and obviously there's
definitely some racist component to all
and it's so sad that this is basically
oh my hair is doing something very
strange like a like a helmet um there's
when you hear at this point in american
politics when you hear oklahoma
republicans want new rules as to how
slavery is taught
we all know it's a complete and total
mess like we we immediately know it's
bad faith
yeah you'd think that they just wouldn't
want to touch that issue alone but now i
feel like they're emboldened like
they're okay with doing such a thing
you'd think that these white oklahoma
representatives would just sort of leave
that issue to other people to sort of
debate or they at least wouldn't be in
the forefront of bringing legislation
having to do with this topic because you
know maybe they're not the most
qualified to do so or maybe it would
just be a bad look but no they don't
care at this point they're going to do
it and they're proud of it
um there is a crazy not great start to
dr oz's republican senate campaign this
is just so funny
i really hope this guy gets crushed
although he certainly has a chance of
winning and as we've said before
pennsylvania senate may end up
determining who controls the senate in
the next session like i'm not writing
off dr oz at all but he's already having
an abortive start to his campaign of the
reporter olivia nutzi
from new york magazine who writes
well well-known reporter
she um published a profile of dr oz
and in the profile she revealed
that
she made a phone call to dr oz's wife
lisa oz
and lisa oz um
didn't want to talk to olivia
and told her to have a nice day and
thought that she had hung up the phone
and instead of hanging up the phone it
connected to the speaker of her car and
she was driving around with dr oz and
they had a four minute conversation
which olivia just stayed on and
overheard
in which
they accused her of lying and uh
swore and said she shouldn't have effing
said this about some of the people
quoted in the story
and it's just another one of these
complete and total humiliations which
is sort of i guess like a technical it's
sort of like a hot mic moment at the end
of the day it's kind of like a
technology
misdeed but already
all of these little on the edges things
getting really weird for dr oz the other
story that came out in the last 24 48
hours pat is that oprah who is sort of
responsible for dr oz kind of even being
a known figure because she featured him
on his on her show for a long time
before he developed his own celebrity
um people were wondering well oprah's
you know an obama supporter and oprah's
on the left as far as we know but
generally speaking she's on the left
she's on the in the limousine left for
lack of a better term what's she going
to say about dr oz and the statement is
like so
um
antiseptic i guess i would call it where
it's basically like we live in a country
where anybody can run for office and dr
oz is doing that and it will be up to
the people of pennsylvania to decide
kind of making the point like like hey
she doesn't vote in pennsylvania it's
not for her to comment it's all already
getting really weird for dr oz
yeah that sounds to me like oprah is
saying well i liked him as a per person
we were good acquaintances and all that
but i would certainly not vote for him
and his politics does not align with
mine yeah that's what i'm hearing there
uh yeah this this story about the butt
dial or uh you know the
what was believed to be a hang-up yeah
but wasn't truly because it was
connected to the car speaker it reminds
me of the butt dial that rudy giuliani
did when he was calling reporters
without realizing it and then having
these like five-minute long
conversations with them not realizing
that he was actually on the phone with
these reporters so yeah definitely just
a technological mishap but if there's
anything that we can learn from this
it's that the oz's took issue with the
reporter writing that uh dr oz is going
to be seen as sort of the new guard of
the republican party yeah and that folks
like him and glenn younkin in virginia
are going to be like the next chapter of
republicans and you'd think that someone
running for
senate as a republican would be proud of
that and proud of the fact that people
are calling him sort of the next wave of
republican candidates but it's actually
something that the authors were upset
over which is really interesting i
wonder if they're sort of embarrassed to
be republicans at the end of the day or
they're trying to see themselves as
moderates but not associate with like
the true trump wing of the party and
they actually see being labeled a
republican as an insult yeah what's
going on there i am really curious as to
how dr mehmet uh i i i need to stop
saying dr oz too because we need to
refer to him as as
memit oz is the candidate i i also
am curious as to what level of
association with the republican party at
large memit oz is going to sort of frame
up for himself we actually have some
early polling data and
it's it's sort of looking okay in the
primary for dr oz so there's an echelon
insights poll from december one to three
which has
met oz at 11
which is the most of any of the
candidates but 63 percent are undecided
important most people are still
undecided but among those who have
decided memit oz is leading
in the democratic polling
john fetterman is leading every single
poll but there's still a lot of
undecided people there as well so like
in a franklin and marshall poll
fetterman is at 27 percent
undecided is 36 so so still a lot of uh
undecided there
there is a december 20th republican
primary poll where mehmet oz is polling
94
to carla sands at 6 that's very very big
uh and in uh also a more recent
democratic primary poll in pennsylvania
fetterman is at 61
with conor lamb and sharif street each
at 13. so this is by no means over but
the early polling is pretty good for
mehmet oz and very good for john
fetterman over on the democratic side
yeah and assuming that it is mehmet oz
versus john fetterman i guess you have
to call it a toss-up at least at this
stage because yeah pennsylvania you can
still say is a blue state but it did go
to trump obviously in 2016 so we can't
be totally sure of that i'm just glad
the democrats do have a strong candidate
in john fetterman running because if it
was one of these boring candidates
someone without a lot of personality
then i think mehmet oz would run all
over them and maybe would swing the
balance in the senate so that's good at
least that we're putting up a fight and
what it may come down to unfortunately
though is if republicans have this red
wave in 2022 that's going to extend in
some of these bluer or purpley states
like pennsylvania is so that may suggest
that oz would be able to win there as
well i think that what we can say we
don't have all the information yet as
you're pointing out and it's december
but i think without question we can say
mehmet oz is a real contender here
and mehmet oz could be the next senator
from senate from pennsylvania
and that seat could hand control to
republicans in the next legislative
session which would be a really really
horrible thing but we'll be covering
that race i don't expect trump to show
up at an oz rally i i think he very well
may go and support lauren beaubert or
lauren beau bear as uh ro khanna
referred to her in colorado i'm not
expecting trump and oz to be in the same
place i suppose that makes sense because
if trump was viewed as too toxic to go
help glenn younkin in virginia yeah then
he's definitely going to be seen as too
toxic to help dr oz i'm sorry mehmet
pennsylvania yeah
all right that does it for today we'll
be back tomorrow with the last show of
the year and the final bonus show of the
year see you then
you